president biden facing criticism today
after speaking first about a spending
bill up on capitol hill and then
afghanistan during his speech we brought
you yesterday today the president had a
new focus and it wasn't the u.s
withdrawal as the race to meet his
self-imposed august 31st deadline
quickly approaches white house
correspondent peter ducey joins us from
the north lawn with that good evening
peter good evening brett officials here
like to boast that right now the
pentagon is pulling off what may be the
largest airlift in history but there
have been several critical days of this
operation that the commander-in-chief
hasn't wanted to talk about it as the
world watches
i've made this a priority for my
administration from the outset he was
talking about cyber security no talk
about afghanistan policy aside from this
punch line mr president if americans are
still in afghanistan after the deadline
what will you do you'll be the first
person i'll call
so what's so fun of course it's a very
important question these are incredibly
serious issues and there are discussions
that are happening internally as the
clock ticks towards a final flight out
of kabul the president's focus on
domestic issues including the buildback
better agenda last night is worrying
some critics
he was wasting precious time this week
burning the phones up pressuring
democrats to vote for a 5 trillion
dollar spending bill and tax bill that's
what he was wasting time on every minute
of his days should be getting all
americans out the top democrat in
congress still backs biden the
judgment about leaving is about judgment
that the president has made i trust his
judgment republicans including some who
served don't we are on the cusp paris of
having the biggest mass hostage
situation in american history it's going
to make 1979 and tehran look like a
sleepover after the president's deadline
to leave the taliban may remain u.s
partners if it makes good on its
commitments to allow people who want to
leave afghanistan to leave that's a
government we can work with but that
could conflict with a long-standing
foreign policy tradition why haven't we
heard the president say
the united states does not negotiate
with terrorists is that still the u.s
policy
well of course it is peter but i would
also say that
there's a reality that the taliban is
currently controlling large swaths of
afghanistan that is a reality on the
ground so they say they don't negotiate
with terrorists what they do is they
have active discussions with the taliban
and officials claim they haven't given
anything to taliban leaders they don't
see this as a quid pro quo but nobody
around here has been able to say what is
going to happen after the us leaves and
the taliban starts stopping afghans who
helps the u.s want to leave too from
leaving two right big question peter
ducey live on the north lawn peter
thanks hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else